para añadir combustible al fuego en lo
que será una semana tensa en la política
estadounidense fue publicado una
conversación telefónica grabada entre
donald trump y el secretario de estado
de georgia obtenida por el diario the
washington post el presidente presiona
hablar la frente berger para recalcular
el resultado del voto presidencial en
georgia para inclinarlo a su favor
la verdad
[Música]
en lugar de boya
y
con nuestras tensiones de ciudad desde
del jardín juego justo antes de que la
cinta fuera publicada por the washington
post
donald trump comentó su conversación con
el secretario en twitter ayer hablé con
el secretario de estado brad razones
perger sobre el condado de fulton y el
fraude electoral en georgia no quiso o
no pudo responder a preguntas como el
fraude de las papeletas bajo la mesa la
destrucción de papeletas los votantes de
fuera del estado los votantes muertos y
más no tienen ni idea
hablando en georgia el domingo por la
noche la vicepresidenta electa kamala
harris condenó las acciones de trump
[Música]
han oído hablar de esa conversación
grabada bueno ciertamente era la voz de
la desesperación sin duda era eso y era
un descarado y audaz abuso de poder por
parte del presidente de eeuu
la casa blanca no ha hecho ningún
comentario sobre las revelaciones que de
inmediato sacudieron políticamente
washington